diddly-dee dee dum dee-dum dee-dum BDD
people like what I do that di dum dum AA
dee dee dum it enhances a song it's
blondie who farted haha a DVD dee dum
welcome back
Oh get Jim Norton and Sam Roberts that
was a good one that was a bad one that's
like waving oh I say I feel like I'm
holding a log right into her something
light a match
none quit is he happier oh I couldn't be
happy get a hold by hand Almighty so the
far fumes don't go on we could just have
teabag oh yeah another one yeah no I
don't even want but now I feel sick
come on that was a bad one it was a bad
well that was a bad one when their total
move it out of this areas quickly that
was the type we like like in my colon is
probably a sideways log that's being
stubborn was that the Vietnamese food
yeah that's the [ __ ] delicious Oh
Thai tomato salad ha ha ha ha yeah
that's great that's a deer hunter fart
well at least outside thing it's past
it's passed through this area quickly oh
did you see what I tweeted I almost had
him too I almost had Collin oh we all
gym at the gym on Jim Norton on Twitter
was very close to having Collin spill
his eggs just calling to talk
zipped his [ __ ] zipper around his
headphone cord so I saw that and I'm
like if he backs up his cord is gonna
rip the whole thing off but I tell you
even though there's no eggs spilled
everywhere it's almost worth it just for
the moment of confusion on Colin's face
when he realizes his headphone wire is
stuck in his hoodie oh you know she's
fun yeah basically anything can happen
anything yeah chef Smith kinda came out
of the closet yes I've heard that yeah I
hear how he did it
please you need advice no no no how he
did it oh please
I'll tell he did it he said oh no you
didn't haha stupid he was doing an
interview with The Huffington Post uh
and he was talking about Roger Ailes
and Smith indicated that Ailes did not
express contempt for homosexuality when
he was around him saying Fox knew
was warm was a warm work environment and
under Al's reign he never treated he
treated me with respect just respect
Smith said he gave me every opportunity
Bible wat so the thing is in this
interview um he didn't really come out
the interviewer was like oh you give you
a hard time about being gay and he's
like no at what exactly
mommy Katherine's already kind of out
wasn't he I think so I mean gay
he's yes myth no well using that he's
our yo documentary like got that like
southern gay thing like Tommy Lee Jones
in JFK oh my god right yeah what do you
have here little references boner
despite what you may think of me missing
you guys plus the other class of issue
in your family I extend to your near
family
yeah very happy Easter last time I did
read I I saw him leaving the building is
are you doing again Thursday with Jim
Norton that's right
oh brother get to the point all right we
know the two of us together call guys
have you done it will be fun have you
done right I I did a long time ago here
well it's much funnier now oh yeah hey
they uh but as I was going in chef Smith
was walking out and he had like a very
brightly colored plaid shirt on and
form-fitting kind of bootcut jeans and
you were like aha good gotcha
that's a left to Center no but I mean I
know right he does you know wait wait
when you say he came out and you start
pulling up pictures of Shep Smith yes it
does become like all eyes which you
could do that anybody know you say is
gay no pictures yeah it's like John
Wayne came out yeah look what he's
looking at
look what he's looking at right and also
like I would go gay he looks come out
look at John Wayne today dad look I know
oh he does he does all the stuff I feel
like Shep Smith does now yes now that
even though he's kind of been out now
that it's very public oh yes it's gonna
come across as like caddy as opposed to
like blunt
you didn't mean right right did you hear
the I don't remember Jim I think was
actually played on a fire guard it did
you hear the weather report he did right
before the Florida hurricane do Busey in
Mexico he says chili today Hot Tamale Oh
God come on anything happen nothing's
right that's not what he said I'm gonna
keep saying that that's good right I
like it thank you this I like it as a
mission statement I've keep it in my
head but no no no I want people I want
to drill at home now people give a
picket or anything can happen for the
content how should we say it though with
what's the inflection I do like that
inflection anything could happen
anything reaches yeah maybe that is too
much Regis anything can happen anything
can happen anything can happen anything
can happen check box comment let's go to
Ted box for comments look at this
emergent bride attacks a new husband
with wine bottle ever sing his giant
penis for the first time yeah that can't
be a stri no I'm not married
hold on let's see what Jeff says that
box for comment I like Jim's original
one thank you anything can happen oh my
god this guy's holding Jim Norton what'd
he do he really should have a second he
was of masturbating in his car cuz he
was trying to stay awake remember when
you first that was your technique many
many years ago yes try stay awake just
tug it a police office he might have
been listening to the show maybe maybe
let's listen to Shep Smith tugging his
prick he likes the new direction of the
show just jerking off to the comedy yeah
uh yeah here was Shep preparing
everybody most people have heard this I
have not but preparing everybody for the
hurricane by the way the hurricane
seemed to get a lot less dangerous after
Donald Trump announced that he wanted to
grab women by the [ __ ] you know what I
mean but everybody stopped talking about
the dangers hurricane and started going
with the [ __ ] thing I heard that clip
Trump said that right yeah now the UM
because a bush was actually with him I
think de menthe the egged him on a
little bit hurt yeah I was said by a
very smart woman yeah this is a this is
a chef but this is what the hurricane do
to the weather report where he said
something like um a lot of times I hate
when it snows and then there's slush all
over my back first of all I could you
see here's the problem
the setup was terrible I know what is it
hired
you just said here's the hurricane due
to the weather report hey what are you
I'm going to tell you now it's like we
could just stop weather reports that
they're causing hurricane look man it's
all I know is oh [ __ ] alright let's play
oh let's play Shep I'm cleaning up my
station
Millburn it ain't on the beach all the
way up to Jacksonville this moves 20
miles to the west and you and everyone
you know are dead all because you can't
survive it it's not possible unless
you're very very lucky Jesus and your
kids die too
you didn't say that yeah I did it
literally pulled from Fox that's
terrible that you don't like that Colin
I think it's offensive your kids die too
what the [ __ ] is he saying that for yeah
we got a problem he's trying to explain
to everybody how dangerous the scenario
is gonna be in Florida last week what
what there's no place I love other ways
go everybody evacuate what if you have
no place to go go to some stupid shelter
that's just the fridges as dangerous as
your house go to a hotel inland what do
you have any money well then guess go
and sit in the parking lot
yeah least you're not getting blood you
stay in your house it save it in the
parking lot no I don't know so you think
you think of the beachfront house is
safer than I think Dana limpar should
just stow stop telling people to
evacuate just say there's a hurricane
coming do what you feel now fart again
did you know Abby's day well trade is
coming into 20 minutes and go I'll save
some for him no he does it he doesn't
want to deal with that know y'all
richard pryor on the set of blue collar
that's I mean this is giving child's
play to him yeah but this is like eight
he's gotten past all I'm tired man I
know you are hunkered out I know yer
poor shreddies tuckered out - me too
taxi dressing was to walk witness to you
if he says his nose crinkles if he says
who farted I'm gonna go you talking to
me are you talking to me no but I be
good tonight good are you talking to me
ten bucks where's that from all right
you got me I don't know I know it's from
one of the school's lazy moves like Eric
Conn's got it is his nose and mouth
inside of his t-shirt yeah like a small
child
getting bad fart double whammy the first
one was fine dude this one's too much
that one's worse this one's worse no but
I'm just saying it's just this
accumulative right now I get that I get
that first one I kind of look you know I
enjoy a good laugh it's a fog you know
we enjoyed the laughter plus I was
enjoyment when I went to Sam now how
quickly you forget
Xabi I was like this is horrible I was
like a hockey puck we went around
laughing to myself oh he's suffering no
this one's not as bad do you watch Shep
Jim most of the trouble went out no
never he's good he speaks his mind on
fox news I like chef fine nobody else is
interested in discussing this for next -
knowing I'm not gonna talk about it for
20 minutes I can you know how you're
doing I'm jamming it and I rock
commercial 20 minute don't worry all
right well then Colin back she needs a
subject back to farts then who you elder
statesman Jesus Christ
back to flatulence to say about him he I
thought Shep was like fine until you
started playing that stupid thing we
telling people their kids are gonna die
you didn't like that I think it's a
little crazy yeah you gotta get a little
place where they can all hide why would
he say your kids are gonna die too
because what did you just say it down
here in the root cellar oh oh yeah uncle
Paul Jesus keep bring them down at a
root cellar it's got a hurricane
evacuation plan sure it is everybody get
down there to huddle and wrote some kind
of evacuation is that yeah the winds
gonna blow in your underpants oh god
damn it
that's Larry Flynt is offering 1 million
for scandals recordings of Donna Troy oh
yes
isn't it as no it's 1 million is like
nothing nowadays whoa whoa mr.
highfalutin
Wow a million is nothing well I guess we
don't realize no offers from 20 years
ago doesn't it Hollywood comedy was
gonna visit us a million dollars is
still a lot of money to some of us
working Joe's
yeah mr. Adam Sandler Netflix movies oh
hey guys you know my motto anything you
have that's a good anything can happen
right
Oh a million dollars yes Larry Flynt is
uh is is good look if somebody's got a
tape of Donald Trump like some guy who
are PA worked on a show who saved a tape
CD I don't know if it's a sex tape but
they could use the million or some chick
that just hooked up with him that
recorded him for whatever reason look
lyrically it's not gonna give anybody a
million dollars it's just yes he would
I'm he would but he's not that's not why
he's doing this it's for its publicity
it's like I have a tape of he also hates
you I have a tape of Trump and Shepard
Smith you know I'll give it to you guys
for a hundred thousand done yeah I bet
you he offered that already years ago I
have a shape of millennion de Becque
he had at eight he had made you a
million dollars years ago for anything
with their like Republicans like any
chemo proven affair and yet stepped down
he [ __ ] he ruined a couple million
dollars is [ __ ] today how many think
it needs to be 10 million oh whoa whoa
but I've never even seen that kind of
money before that Trump language though
you might probably giving away hundreds
of millions that's good that's good
no I it's just it's the same way all the
poor companies like that guy yeah ken
bone yes who's got the $100,000 offer to
do a live webcam show nobody thinks he's
actually gonna do the live webcam show
but you attach yourself to the news
story and the press release goes out and
all of a sudden everybody's talking
about your every stroke about Larry
Flynt again every was talking about
hustler he's talking about soda pop cam
whatever and Ken bone there he is there
he actually he's dressed like a certain
producer though in the lava this one ah
how great would it be to get rolling a
week supply of ken bone t-shirts so he
just had to he had to choose the editor
year to go back and forth between scrub
daddy and Ken Bowman well that's sweater
at least did you see all the other Ken
bone reddit stuff know about all this oh
yeah baby was uh he like Jennifer
Lawrence
butthole I know he said awesome yeah he
did oh yeah he did he goes uh
it goes out to everybody and then he
starts talking about you know the
fappening right and he goes you know
only only bad people would would would
look at those photos and by that I mean
myself I like her butthole was what he
wrote so he was on reddit and he did a a
new day nama right but he didn't change
his username
he made a rookie mistake and didn't
change his username for AMA you're
supposed to create a new username right
so instead he just used the username you
already had so all anybody had to do was
click the username and just scroll
through everything he's ever posted on
reddit and he's talking about not only
liking Jennifer Lawrence's butthole this
is what he wrote maybe she should have
been more careful with her pics but the
bad guys are still the ones who sought
them out and looked at them by which I
mean guys like me I call her butthole
and I liked it Oh what just is he trying
to be funny I think in that moment he
was trying to be funny now it's about
three months ago he's like is that the
equivalent of going what has two thumbs
and a ha this guy
Ken's a real corker what'd he do for a
living uh uh I don't know what he does
for a living I know he's still undecided
he won't declare who he's voting for
Mitch he knows he just likes the idea
people asking him he just wanted is kind
of intriguing to him he just wants to
make sure that the world goes out there
and votes he's got a point
yeah without voting what do we really
have it's true I mean that does what
separates us from other countries yeah
you're not wrong
sin separates us from the animals in
other countries right right this point
it says he works in coal and energy so
I'm assuming he's a trump supporter
because Hillary Clinton said the thing
about wanting all the coal people to go
out of business
sure well I hope they don't have any
jobs anymore why she said it was really
rude to she's like if you work for call
your mother's a [ __ ] in the process you
said the secret service yeah exactly
what she was cursing at them he also
found out you know cuz you could you
there's there's threads for everything
on reddit yeah and he
favorite porn he likes it so much that
he writes about it like he posts on the
board oh you know what kind of porn he's
into
hold on let's figure it out yeah
bestiality porn no be alle disgusting
like that now what come all da tell me
Sammy pregnant transsexual close what he
likes pregnant porn uh all the human
submarines he did he said he loves those
human submarine hahahaha way is kind of
beautiful I guess right I mean that's a
jerk oh well it's the miracle birth so
it's maybes you know it's great in a way
like hey I'm lucky I'm not her husband
know you're talking about how much like
looking at the bellies and bathing suits
and stuff you start not just like oh I
like that son even I hear that that's
not even that weird oh don't you think
it's funny and creepy that he likes to
put you jerks off to pregnant women no
that's not even that's not not nuts but
the we're waiting I forget exactly I'm
tired
right it's so funny before you started
that sentence I was like where the
hell's he gonna go with this yeah cuz
first he goes it's disgusting then he
goes that's not even the naughty part
and I knew there was there's nothing he
could say he didn't have anything always
like I'm tired no I did have shouting oh
wait no because I was I had another
point I can't remember oh you know it's
like they people love to just rip you
down once they build you up before yeah
this owners war his fault because I mean
he posted it in a public forum it wasn't
like this was private [ __ ] they posted
it before he was famous it was his fault
for he's not changing his stupid reddit
name here's what it was his fault for
for doing an AMA he should say I don't
have anything why would I do an AMA I'm
a guy who asked a question at a debate
with a red sweater on I don't need to be
doing an AMA the more I do the closer I
get to them destroying me so no I'm not
doing an AMA yeah but how's he supposed
to know that
he's gay look at him with the questions
comments a great offense to that oh I
really was offended by that I was
uncalled for
I mean I you're right you did he just
wanted to be famous look what's the big
deal nowadays she's gonna be gone in a
week yeah
he's WikiLeaks even if he didn't do an
ama they would have found your concern
you're concerned about WikiLeaks I'm
really I'm concerned about our national
discourse I think we need is a big pot I
think you're right your national
discourse has suffered
I think it's coarsened you know I
they turned his internet off Julian
Assange I know you know did it they're
saying Ecuador Ecuador Ecuador Quinton
country cuz he's in London in the
Ecuadorian Embassy yeah so why would
Ecuador do when they're letting him stay
in their embassy because we paid maybe
maybe I just going on around here to him
a couple of billion yeah I don't know
else gonna be oughta turn it all we did
nobody knows a hundred percent yeah but
uh you know he's he's hooking up with
our bet what did you hear who went into
his [ __ ] embassy room what you didn't
hear about that I heard if it's Shep
Smith I don't want to hear this who is
it Pam Anderson 90s hot chick alert
they're saying that Blau Pam Anderson
went into the embassy yesterday like
it's same time everybody was reporting
that his internet got shut off Pam
Anderson was going up to visit Julian
Assange
maybe he shut it off so nobody would be
able to tape oh yeah because he was
giving it to a real good savage yeah and
they were like where's your internet
needs like I don't know Ecuador must
turn it off leave me alone right you
know I need a I need a seven minutes in
heaven you know but she leave me alone
I'd still do with her with Pam you know
who the hell wouldn't I mean with that
kind of Frank talk though it's just
anything can happen or a lot on in chat
you know what I mean is you it will take
me on I'd give it to her you would yeah
give it to her good real savage comes in
you go honey I'm gonna show you the full
monty you're just standing there nude
yeah it's a nice little belly to kiss oh
yeah I figure she's cherry pushing 30 oh
yeah
okay these are old photos Jim oh these
are very old phone look at her boobs
Wow we can know it anywhere in a
brassiere I like it I like it I call it
over shoulder Bubba German word stop
I liked it I liked it Julian Assange's
internet turned off for a day and he's
like his definition of hot chicks is
like remember Baywatch he's just unaware
of who the hot chicks are now anymore
cuz Internet's gone Oh Pam people are so
shitty to out look how ugly shoe if you
were just that's my slippers don't take
photos yes I mean the discourse is
really forcing in my saying that yeah
you miss it you're shitty but like you
you can't be famous for being hot for a
long time in cash in on I understand and
then be surprised when you're not hot
anymore and people comment on that as
well that's just you know I know that
but yeah
hey you're ready as part of the course
in another culture yeah it's a good
point you think that the discourse is
corseting yeah but yeah so uh Julian
Assange is Internet was taken out by I
guess Ecuador but nobody knows why or
why a quiet impales bill you see that
maybe he's Swedish right yeah I am
uliana Sahni you should try that next
time you're down at Gary's well I liked
when he had what's his name and you're
saying that I was Tim Matheson you say
my lightweighting was better than well
Tim I know you did a good job but well
that's a good is that's actually really
good
I'm an essential Reagan well it doesn't
sound anything like Colin Quinn no he'll
thank you yeah hey Reagan
yeah I could have been that movie you
should have been in that movie killing
Reagan well you sound too much like him
though yeah yeah sometimes would
overshadow the whole thing some jelly
beans talk maybe two well I don't wanna
say jelly beans it'll mess up the
impression I don't know well alright
just the one where they say words jelly
a jelly beans mommy
yeah it's great hey Ronald how you do
sounds good I'm good then the new shows
going great oh thank you very much Ron I
like to do a in person and incorporate
them into now that's really into real
life right right we can start asking
Ronald about WikiLeaks and stuff like
that
well WikiLeaks oh my friend Julian's
here hello
I am enjoying being on demon Sam show ha
ha no he sounds quite that samhitas very
sweet it's good this is sound like the
Swedish Chef Pam Anderson she reminds me
of a Swedish girl is that why you love
her so much
yeah she's like the sweetest became very
good Jim probably seven joke with
Swedish bikini team in his act in the
nineties oh yeah no I have never heard
any guy that would close with whatever
the hell he used to close the fleet
enema whatever you criticizing my enema
bit for me what was the animal yet no
shape without going hey look at this
girl wouldn't mind those a Swedish
bikini team in the crowds like uh I
would have said that actually Jersey
house frowns like no I I she played an
enema bit wrote had an animal even know
that I don't know number it's not good
well tell me about it I was doing bit
while ago I have an enema and I pull out
of a bath like a problem well yet was it
was in the eye not like a prop a project
is it a paperback you'd bring an enema
with you yes I would I just a prop a
prop it's also like an enema joke so
it's a double problem I would carry on
said wow it's funny I remember the
weight of it I carry it in a paper bag
and put it on this stool and then at the
end I would pull it out and act like
shocked at what it was and how I was
addicted and I would read the back of it
I don't understand
I was the enema Bobby what's the joke
cuz they were addicting and I would talk
about enema junkies
oh so it's did it say on the box that
they were addictive yes and you would
then make jokes about people were
addicted to enemas yes just making all
your poopy jokes no it was this very
high energy it wasn't good it wasn't but
I like like these reading it then he
goes back to the mic okay caution yeah
no kidding do not use my first of all of
you using this more than three times a
day you've got another problem
yeah just one yeah no witticism
a well-written witticism about each of
the line in the warning i have to be on
it it's not what I'm proud of
Kyle you didn't know Jim at that time
did you no no I wish you had I met him
right after and leaders like 94 did you
respect from your fellow comedians for
the enema joke
well I don't crowd II hung about what
they did of course he did him leaving
the horse probably try to buy it off him
dopes running around route 80 and 78
swapping shitty depressing sex stories
and shitty bed oh my god yeah you're
right though that was a closer that way
[ __ ] get big laughs dude take a quick
break before our guests get here
all right well I'll give you one too
before we do I used to when I first in
comedy I had a little like semi mask
that I wear once in a while and do a
character like like this hair face that
I [ __ ] coupla tops and I'd be like
hey I had like a half like a plastic
mask right above my head is it like I
don't understand what you mean like a
Zorro mask no it was like a face it
almost looked like a fake nose it up a
lip and I was like hey don't just do it
I don't know what he's like everybody's
to do with him to just be the bot it
like it'd be the nose and mouth and you
just put it on I know I just put it on
it wasn't attached to the back just put
on here and any other guy I did a couple
of times Wednesday was it smiling
government what would you say I forget
but was it I was doing I was doing some
kind of character with it what did it
look like it looked funny it looked like
a different face I'm sure it didn't look
funny
it didn't look funny none of the
crackers because what is that why you
only did it a couple times because the
crowd liked it too much because I think
some comedian was probably like hey man
you know that's like a proper some those
are gone the communities in respective
I love stories of Colin gone with his
instinct and being 100% wrong it is
that's that's probably I mean going for
it it's it's not a dissimilar type of
thinking to you going into the old
Crocodile Dundee story when you went in
and decided to rerun oh it's much
different
everybody screwed up early in comedy
having the audacity to hand in a script
but if you but my mentality was
literally waiting to hear from them like
you know I mean like just I wasn't even
like a headliner can be I just waiting
like when are they gonna [ __ ] get
back to me on this right that was really
another level of what did you get to
every [ __ ] I went in the business now
I be like what off [ __ ] because I'm
sure that by the way requests on Twitter
could you say which one is the giraffe
and I messed up that one always after I
was a crocodile anything do you think I
should do yeah no that was a dream and
baby do you think I could give my old
car love Dundee script she played a Paul
Schrader and see what he thinks I think
you should I took longer than three days
to write I'll tell you that I would
actually give I'd pay a lot of money for
that script so was I so what I would you
do with it I told you what I did I took
the plot and incorporated me as his
co-lead and just made me lead him around
New York and be like hey Paul it's like
what's this this is an Irish bar hey
what's this hey this is you know Italian
salami
would you hand it to I hand it to the
director in the producer Jim has this I
know that shocks me every time why what
did you do at the physical script where
is it did you have no computer right in
those days don't compute right yeah so I
[ __ ] my poor girlfriend typed it up
and I poured it in and handed it and
then waited for their response do you
think it was quality talk to the guy I
had one line of the movie and I'm going
what do you think of it like I asked him
like about the script John Cornell it
was any me director owned if he
remembers what'd he say
he's like well yeah we're gonna get what
is whatever no look I feel a little bad
[ __ ] version New York
when did your women the movie came I was
like say this when did your ego die down
to the point where you wouldn't have the
audacity to do something that happy
no still there's still something in you
that goes like I better I better submit
something here yeah that that same
person is still there I've taxi
coincidentally taxi drivers one of the
few movies that I can't see them I
couldn't have done anything but no
[ __ ] masterful you go you go see
movies you know like I do I go like it's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
they sent that up the whole second act
was like shake I'll tell you what do you
ever rewrite movies just because now
not anymore Benedetto said rejection a
waste of my valuable time I forgot yeah
all your time being wasted